Clustered object offers several advantages. First of
all, the object reference is the same on
all the nodes, so that's very very important.
Regardless of which node a particular server is
executing, they all have the same object reference.
But under the covers, you can now have
incremental optimization of the implementation of the object.
According on the usage pattern, you can have
different levels of replication of the same
object, so it allows for incremental optimization. And
you can also have different implementations of
the same object, depending on the usage pattern.
And it also allows for the potential
for dynamic adaptations of the representations. The advantage
of course of the replication is that, the
object references can access the respective replicas independently.
And this means that you have less locking of
shared data structures. Let's think about the process object
as a concrete example. So if you think about
the process object, it's one per CPU and with
mostly read only. And, and therefore page fault handling
can start on all of these different processors, independent
of one another. And if they touch different regions
of the address space, then the path taken by the
page fault handling for all these different threads can be
different. So what that means is that, page fault handling
for instance, will scale in this case using this as
a concrete service with the number of processes. It'll scale to
the number of processes. And this is important because, page
fault handling is something that is going to happen often, and so
you want to make sure it scales with the number of
processes. On the other hand, if we want to get rid
of a region, then the destruction of region
may take more time because the region may
have multiple representations, and all of the representations
of that particular region has to be gotten
rid of. And so destruction of a region
may take more time but that's okay because
you don't expect region destructions to happen as
often as handling page faults to service the ongoing
needs of the thread. So, the principle again is to make sure
that the common case is optimized, the common case is page fault
handling. Region creation, region destruction. All of those things happen
more rarely and it is okay if those functionalities take a little bit more time.